hey everyone it's joanna here today
we'll be specifically working on
our inner and outer thighs this is one
of
the most requested workouts so we will
be hitting
those small muscles that most of us tend
to neglect
there will be lots of pulses small
movements but you will really feel
your inner thighs and outer thighs on
fire
so let's get started
let's start with a quick warm-up stand
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointed forward let's get into a nice
squat okay and raise your legs to the
side
so there will be lots of lateral
movement
deep squat and just gently
raise your leg to the side and you
should feel the work on
your outer thighs keep going good
a nice gentle warm up to wake the lower
body muscles
out and squat push your butt back
and to the side okay point your toes out
feel the squeeze on your outer
thighs remember throughout this workout
it's going to be slow movements
but i want you to really engage your
inner and
outer thighs good one more
left and right
okay step in the middle let's get into a
side lunge
so to the right back into the center
and to the left again you should feel
the stretch
on your inner thighs as well as a
squeeze on your outer glutes
remember to push with your heels okay
push squeeze your butt alternate sides
squeeze and down good
give me two more on each side push it
and remember to stand tall chest forward
push that's one more and push
good now step wide with the toes pointed
out
i want you to reach for the floor squat
and up okay so it's a nice gentle
white squat push your butt back and feel
the stretch
on your hamstrings one more
squat and up all right the first workout
is going to be a sumo squat okay so
same thing toes pointed out and let's
get into a deep
squat good down and up i want you to
really
push out feel the stretch on the inner
thighs
and feel the squeeze on your outer
thighs and glutes
as you come up okay so push out
squeeze down and up
nice easy movement i want your knees
to be pointing out not forward okay
there will be lots of
white stunts in this workout pointing
out
back down out and down
go as low as you can and feel the
squeeze
on your inner thighs good 20 seconds
let's challenge ourselves get onto our
toes okay
and now give me small sumo squat
pulses good up and down
balance yourself last two more
good and back up
okay good it's going to be a side lunge
with a knee
lift okay so start in the center step to
the side
back up raise your knee up okay so
remember
again where are we working on your outer
thighs
and your inner thigh so push up
raise your core raise your knee up if
this is too tough
tap bring it up push it back
tap bring it up okay step
knee up step and knee up
good keep going side lunge
push with your heels that's one more
and just shake it out
okay still working on one side okay
curtsy lunge for this curtsy lunge i
want you to point
both toes outwards so left leg forward
right leg back toes pointer forward
right leg on your tiptoe get down into a
cutsy lunge cross over
push it out back down and up
good so again remember it's all about
outwards movement
point your knees out push up through
your heels
back down and up so you should feel it
on your left outer glutes and thighs
okay
good keep going down and
up down and up
nice just working on one side for the
second round
we will repeat on the other leg down
and up and again are you ready for the
challenge
20 seconds step tip toe let's go
pulse 20 seconds
feel the burn feel the shake that's what
we want okay
keep going push it out nice
nice balance last three
two one and up
all right a short break okay lateral
squat walk so stand shoulder width apart
squat down
say low i want you to move to your right
and back
to your left the whole goal here is to
stay low
and feel the squeeze on your
outer thighs as you as you move
side to side so it's not a fast movement
it's a slow movement
but the key is to stay low good
stay low push your butt back keep going
left and right do not come up right now
you have three seconds left let's go
out and in out and in
well done well if you have been doing my
workouts
you will know that i like to include a
little bit of
high intensity movement to get your
heart rate up and to burn fat
and so for the final workout it's going
to be a cardio blaster
crease cross squat okay so step right
squat down criss cross squat and
crisscross
okay same thing point your toes out
squat feel the stretch and inner thighs
back down
and crisscross good there you go
if this is too much for you you can
remove
the jumps and just criss cross
and step out if not stay with me
this is your final workout for this
circuit and we want to repeat
the entire circuit once more do you feel
the burn
let's keep going breathe
three two one
up very good okay let's start with the
first workout
sumo squad okay so step right toes
pointed out
and catch your breath down and up
and remember to push your knees out all
right
let's do this together second round
give me your best effort down up
down and up push your butt back
squeeze the glutes at the top but do not
jerk
unlock your knees okay so nice and easy
down and up squeeze good
squeeze right here
keep going squeeze it squeeze it for one
count
back down push it out
step wide okay i want to see a really
wide
stance one more
and now are we ready let's go tiptoe
pulses 20 seconds you're shaking i can
see that
i'm shaking too but we're in this
together so let's keep pulsing
ten more seconds left lift your heels up
let's go
small movement lots of pulses
feel that burn and up
okay side lunge with a knee lift okay
let's work on this side in the middle
step to the side
raise your knee up to the side and
drive your knee up good so brace your
core
find that balance and
there you go one step at a time
do not rush through the workout
look straight ahead chest up
step push your butt back point your toes
up back down up
good suck the belly in engage your core
work on your abs as well up very good
all right so we have worked on our left
leg now
right leg forward left leg back toes
pointed outwards okay in a straight line
could see lunge so let's get down and
lunge good so small movement
you should feel the work on your right
outer glutes
and hips small movement there you go
remember that
your body should be facing forward not
to the side okay
face forward curtsy lunge
so your legs should be in a straight
line
down up down and up good
push go as low as you can try to get
your knee
to touch the floor there you go nice
feel the burn do not come up right now
let's keep going
few more down and up
and this is your favorite part let's go
tiptoe ready small pulses
raise your car find your balance 20
seconds
stay with me feel that burn
i am sweating keep going
pulse pulse last few more stay low
three two one oh my gosh
okay this is considered your
rest lateral squat walk okay start low
let's go to the left and back
to the right all right so your goal
remember
is to stay in a low squat position do
not come up right now
maintain this position
push squeeze your thighs squeeze your
glutes
feel the contraction good we want to
maintain
that constant squeeze
keep going one more left
and back up all right final
cardio blaster and the good news is you
will get
a one minute break okay if you're with
me
let's finish this round together
high energy guys step out toes pointed
out
let's go deep squat and crisscross deep
squat
and cross good there you go
push it out and paste your breathing
nice remember step
wide crisscross and change the other
side
crisscross change good halfway there
breathe you got this you are almost
there
guys you're halfway through your workout
push it out give me three more
two last one and
up all right very
very well done that is the end of
your first round take a short break
drink some water
keep yourself hydrated and for the
second circuit
if you have a mat grab a mat
[Music]
right second circuit grab your mat okay
for this circuit we'll be staying on our
mat throughout the entire workout
there will be lots of small movements
but these movements will really help to
tone up
your glutes as well as your hips so
let's get down onto the mat
let's start with the first workout which
is fire hydrant
start on all fours what i want to do is
raise your left leg up
extend it out bring it back and back
down okay
again small controlled movement
i don't want you to swear your hips
left and right it's just your left leg
up and down so lift it up squeeze
your outer glutes and then extend
for one count squeeze it even more bring
it back
and down so every movement
you should really engage your mind
to the muscles good up
extend back down and now i just want
small pulses okay up
up squeeze it good
do you feel your left
outer thighs that's what we want squeeze
raise it up as high as you can up
and good all right side
leg raise get down onto the mat
raise your left leg up squeeze again
working on our outer glutes squeeze
point it and up okay so your
arms should just be supporting your
upper body everything
should be focused on your left leg up
and down point it
and down keep it going
do not rest your leg
just a gentle tap back up and
up good again for the final 20 seconds
you know the drill let's say up small
pulses
good hold it and just breathe
hold it good so let's work on one side
for this round and for the next round
we'll change the other side that's three
more up
squeeze and good now place your left leg
in front
extend your right leg this is to work on
the inner thigh
of your right side okay so point lift
down and up again it's a very small
move but you should feel the engagement
and the squeeze
on your right inner thigh down and up
and
down and up good squeeze it as high as
you can squeeze
lift it up squeeze up
let's feel more squeeze it as high as
you can okay feel the squeeze
up last one and good
okay now lie on your
back feet flat on the floor
instead of our regular bridge what we
want to do is frog bridge
so bring your heels together and push
your knees
out okay i want you to maintain this
position throughout the workout
support your body and now let's drive it
up squeeze back
down up and squeeze
so you should feel the work on your
inner thighs as well as
your outer glutes and hips good
squeeze up remember with every movement
hold for one count at the top
drive it down push it back up and down
your knees should be pointing outwards
throughout the entire workout
push up and down good so heels
together up squeeze imagine that's a
straight line
pulling you up and down
breathe and now let's stay up and just
pulse
good there you go feel that burn
small pulses stay high good
up and tend this position squeeze
squeeze nice last three more seconds
that's one more and back down
all right so guess what final cardio
blaster
plank thruster so start in a high plank
position
what i'm going to do is jump out in a
white sumo stance
back down and push yourself back okay
remember that your butt
should be facing the floor so do not do
this this is wrong
but down push yourself back jump
hands off push yourself back hands off
good get into a white squat
and chest up keep going
one more push it back up
and back down all right
let's repeat the entire circuit once
more so let's start with
fire hydrant we have worked on our left
leg let's work
on our right side okay so start on all
fours
again remember the engagement is on this
muscle
right here legs up push it back
bring it in back down lift it up
squeeze and in
there you go keeping your hips squared
do not tilt too much to the left side
okay
support your body with your arms
squeeze it in back down
one step at a time squeeze in
and down up good a few more
got to balance out the other side and
now let's stay
up and just pulse squeeze
squeeze and push
that small muscle let's wake it up push
squeeze up and down
as high as you can stay with me feel the
burn last one more
and back down all right now let's
lie on your left side now let's work on
your right
outer thighs okay so support yourself
point
raise it up tap and
up again the focus is on your right
leg that's it everything else just relax
support your body and just really focus
on your right thighs up tap down
up and down okay
stay up good that's one more
and you know the drill let's go small
pulses
this is the killer good
only 20 seconds up squeeze
keep going few more
up nice let's tone your hips up
that's one more and now place your right
leg down
forward extend your left side and now
we're working
on your left inner thigh okay now raise
it up
as high as you can point it down squeeze
don't worry if you can't raise your leg
too high up
what i want you to focus on is your
inner thigh
muscle okay down up squeeze
and up good there you go
feel the squeeze on the inner thigh
again don't worry if you can't
raise it too high up as long as you're
feeling
the right muscle working up
tap down up and up
good okay now let's lie down onto the
floor
frog bridge okay so heels
facing each other knees pointed out
support your upper body
and ready let's drive your butt up
squeeze it one count
back down up and just a gentle tap
and up good remember you're always
pushing
out up squeeze and back
down now let's try
double down double
at the top two small pulses
back down two small pulses
and back down good more
muscle activation
keep going double back down
push it out breathe
and now for the final 20 seconds let's
stay
up pulse pulse good
keep going knees out
heels together butt up
pulse push it up
feel the squeeze remember to squeeze
your glutes
and up and back
down okay we're not stopping right now
final workout okay plank thruster so
choose your option if you want to jump
you can if not
just step in all right so start up
and let's go out back out
in up and release your hands
get into a deep white squat
push it out in and back out
let's go let's finish this workout
strong let's bring up the speed out and
in
speed it up and you are
done okay very
very well done let's end the workout
with a quick
cooldown okay so just sit on your mat
what i'm going to do is bring your heels
together
get into a butterfly position and just
gently move your thighs up and down
all right release the tension and just
slowly
hug your feet together and just
stretch it out all right just go as low
as you can
and just relax
and breathe okay i want you to start to
bring your heart rate down
and now point your left leg out
we've done lots of work on our inner
thighs and outer thighs
so let's stretch those muscle out and
just gently
reach for your toes okay if you want to
just reach and feel the stretch
good
and now change the other side right leg
extend it out and just
reach
and breathe
all right and now slowly come back up
all right and you are done with today's
training focusing on your inner thighs
as well as
your outer thighs if you enjoy this
workout be sure to give this workout a
thumbs up
share this workout on with your
girlfriends and do check out my youtube
channel
for a lot more workout videos healthy
recipes
meal plans workout plans as well as
nutritional tips
and i will see you next time all the
best
you